It's time to look back at updating our
forecast view in phone landscape mode.
What we have now with a huge app bar,
gives the user almost no context
to use the list, and the list contains
a huge amount of white space.
The design that we have for
the forecast landscape you eliminate,
is most of the app bar.
Placing it underneath
the scrolling list.
We're going to fix the width of
our forecast list at 360 dp.
This isn't as bad as it might sound,
since the whole goal for
this is to eliminate
interior white space.
And this guarantees that the interior
white space is constant.
We're eventually going to pad
the top of the list by 16dp.
But we'll save that for later.
We're going to do these changes
inside of the forecast fragment,
inside of the layout land directory,
because the next code pull moves
the app bar layout into the fragment.